Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Grazie HAL, per aver accettato l'invito.
Oggi è lui, l'attore
principale della giornata.
Lui è un esoscheletro,
un esoscheletro attivo.
HAL è l'unico esoscheletro
attivo al mondo.
E se lui è l'attore principale,
io cosa ci faccio quassù?
Io e HAL ci siamo conosciuti
qualche anno fa.
Ci siamo poi frequentati,
e io mi sono innamorato di lui.
Sì, me ne sono innamorato;
perché HAL, per me, è stata una risposta
ad una domanda che mi sono sempre posto
da quando ho incominciato
a fare la mia professione:
come posso aiutare i pazienti?
Come posso aiutare le persone
che sono diventate pazienti?
Sì, perché il paziente
è una persona, non è una patologia.
Il paziente è una persona che ha perso
la sua condizione di normalità,
ma che ha ancora
delle potenzialità residue.
Questo è il paziente.
Parlavamo di normalità.
La normalità è una cosa
molto importante, per noi.
La normalità significa poter fare
quello che vogliamo,
quando vogliamo,
come vogliamo.
Significa che però,
per poter fare tutte queste cose,
molti sistemi e molti organi
del nostro corpo
devono essere collegati e coordinati -
oltre che, naturalmente, comandati.
Uno di questi sistemi,
che noi abbiamo, è il sistema nervoso.
Il sistema nervoso lo possiamo dividere
in sistema nervoso centrale
e sistema nervoso periferico.
Lo chiameremo "il" sistema nervoso.
Il sistema nervoso parte dal cervello,
e attraverso la colonna
migliaia di filamenti, che sono i nervi,
partono dal cervello
e arrivano ai nostri muscoli.
Il cervello ordina di fare un movimento,
il muscolo esegue il movimento:
stendi il ginocchio, stendi il ginocchio.
Come possiamo semplificare un po'
la spiegazione del sistema nervoso?
Be', possiamo provare a immaginarcelo
come il sistema elettrico di casa nostra.
Arriviamo a casa,
schiacciamo l'interruttore,
si accende la lampadina:
sistema nervoso perfetto, normale.
Arriviamo a casa,
schiacciamo l'interruttore,
non si accende la lampadina:
lesione midollare.
La lesione midollare
è un evento traumatico
che determina l'interruzione delle vie
che partono dal cervello
e arrivano ai nostri muscoli.
Ciò significa che il cervello dà l'input
per poter muovere il ginocchio,
e il ginocchio non si muove.
La World Health Organization
dice che ogni anno, a livello mondiale,
ci sono 150.000 nuovi casi
di lesioni midollari.
Sempre la stessa World Health Organization
ci dice che l'età media di  insorgenza
sono 16 anni.
Ciò significa
che un adolescente di 16 anni
la sera prima corre,
e il giorno dopo è in carrozzina.
Ma quindi, HAL cosa può fare
per queste persone?
Beh, intanto "Hal" è una sigla:
Hybrid Assisted Limb.
È una scoperta del professor Sankai
dell'Università di Tsukuba, in Giappone,
il quale ha scoperto
i segnali bio elettrici.
Il segnale bioelettrico
è un segnale molto fine
che può essere captato
sulla superficie della pelle
attraverso dei semplici adesivi,
come quello per l'elettrocardiogramma.
Semplicissimo.
Hal ha la possibilità
di leggerlo, di amplificarlo,
e di restituirlo ai motori.
Cioè, HAL ha la possibilità
di poter andare a ricostruire
quello che si chiama
"feedback neuromuscolare".
Che cos'è il feedback neuromuscolare?
Be', nel nostro cervello
noi abbiamo fondamentalmente rappresentato
tutto il nostro corpo,
e tutti i nostri movimenti.
Se per un certo periodo
noi non utilizziamo
parte del nostro corpo,
come appunto quando abbiamo
una lesione midollare,
la nostra immagine
di quel corpo diminuisce.
Neuroplasticità: il nostro cervello
è sempre in movimento.
Hal, grazie appunto
alla possibilità di poter muoversi
secondo le intenzioni
di chi lo sta vestendo,
ha la possibilità
di poter andare nuovamente
a far capire al cervello
che, se dice a un ginocchio di stendersi,
il ginocchio si stende.
Ha la possibilità
di poter andare a rigenerare
quelle connessioni
che si erano perse con la lesione.
In buona sostanza, ha la possibilità
di riabilitare, ri-abilitare:
rendere nuovamente abili
le persone a fare qualcosa.
Questo può fare Hal, per queste persone.
Nel novembre 2020 siamo stati contattati -
il mio team è stato contattato
dalla sede europea della casa madre,
che ci ha detto -
è riuscita a prendere in carico
un caso molto importante.
Noi abbiamo detto:
fateci l'inquadramento clinico,
così almeno riusciamo a capire
di che cosa si stia parlando.
Christopher, un ragazzo all'epoca
dell'incidente ventottenne,
ha avuto, mentre era
in vacanza, un trauma.
Si è rotto il collo, dalla quinta
alla settima vertebra cervicale.
Ciò significa tetraplegia:
perdita dell'utilizzo delle mani,
delle braccia e delle gambe.
A seguito dell'incidente, da dove era
è stato trasportato a Singapore,
e hanno fatto un intervento
di neurochirurgia.
Fatto l'intervento di neurochirurgia,
con un aereoambulanza è stato trasferito
in Svizzera, dove risiede.
Arrivato in Svizzera, ha fatto otto mesi
di riabilitazione intensissima:
tutti i giorni,
ore e ore di riabilitazione.
Gli hanno fatto fare di tutto.
Alla fine di questi otto mesi, gli dicono:
Christopher, complimenti,
hai fatto dei grandissimi miglioramenti.
Sei stato bravissimo:
noi siamo contentissimi,
perché sei stato bravissimo.
Il tuo tronco è perfetto,
è molto più stabile rispetto a prima.
Bravo. Complimenti.
Li, però, c'è la carrozzina.
Sì, perché tanto
non riuscirai a camminare.
Però, attenzione,
non potrai neanche spingerti.
Perché la forza delle tue braccia
non sarà sufficiente.
Sentito questa storia,
con il mio team, a marzo del 2021,
abbiamo detto: proviamo.
Non sappiamo dove possiamo andare:
proviamo, proviamo.
Siamo arrivati da lui, e abbiamo detto:
Christopher, qui partiamo.
Ma andiamo via senza GPS.
È un viaggio che faremo così:
lo costruiremo giorno dopo giorno.
Abbiamo lavorato molto anche noi.
Lui, Christopher, ha lavorato tantissimo:
lo abbiamo fatto voltare sul letto,
gli abbiamo fatto fare
pilates neurologico,
lo abbiamo messo
su delle macchine incredibili,
gli abbiamo fatto fare di tutto.
Lui? Lui ha lavorato tantissimo.
Ogni tanto gli cambiavamo la batteria
e lui, felice come una Pasqua,
riprendeva il suo lavoro.
Bravo.
Che cosa abbiamo fatto?
Lo possiamo vedere,
che cosa abbiamo fatto.
Ecco.
(Video)
(Applausi)
(Grida del pubblico)
(Grida)
Fantastico!
(Applausi)